[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we have a very special guest today Robin
farm and farm Ian what's uh thanks for
coming on to the show thanks so much for
having me today
we're really excited to chat you our
speaker an author an investor you our
patient s CEO yes your book from two
years ago
you're also working on some really cool
healthcare revolution products as well
this is all really exciting you're
writing another book so let's let's
start unpacking all of this epicness
maybe we start with the insanity of this
healthcare revolution AI and robotics
sensors at home care instead of actually
going into the hospital digital
revolution of therapeutics like whoa yes
so we're seeing a massive shift right
now happening and it's really moving
healthcare out of the clinic in the
hospitals and into the patient's home
virtually or even to your corner
drugstore like CVS or Walgreens there
are a lot of different technologies that
are really helping make that happen most
especially sensor technology and AI
combined is helping create this class
called point of care Diagnostics and
what that means is a diagnostic device
that comes to you versus you having to
go to the doctor's office or the
hospital or the ER you can now have
things like even 12 to 15 lead EKG
monitoring shirts that our ICU quality
used in the ICU and can be used at home
we have things like air monitoring
devices they stick right on your ear on
your iPhone and it's called cell scope
and it's about $99 so instead of at 2:00
in the morning going to the emergency
room with a little kid because he has an
earache you just stick this in their ear
the AI will analyze it and it will flag
it and if you need to see a physician
you can do so on demand
the app right in video form so really
seeing this massive shift out of the
clinic out of the ER out of the hospital
into the home so now I can go to
Walgreens or CVS and go and pick up this
point of Terror point of care diagnostic
cool some of them are sold at drugstore
chains like that some of them are
available online it depends on on which
one you're talking about that one for
the kids so crucially kids like oh my
ear my ear and it's like okay let's
actually take a look quick and then we
look and that we can video chat with the
doctor exactly sometimes you can save on
cost because in time and not sometimes
saving on cost so a friend of mine
actually went through this exact
scenario recently and posted about it on
Facebook and her little kid had an
earache in the middle of the night they
went to one of the emergency rooms down
the street from their house and it cost
them 27 thousand dollars just walking
into an ER is a ridiculous amount of
money so for this $99 gadget right that
that takes the place you no longer have
to bring up kicking and screaming kids
somewhere it's 2:00 in the morning
especially if you're you know imagine
it's wintertime and it's freezing out
and there are already sick I mean just
for one point of care diagnostic
let alone the other ones that are coming
on the market things like stethoscopes
or ultrasound machines that you can now
have for $300 a month subscription model
wait why I know isn't not so cool so
Phillips has one on the market that is
$300 a month to rent anything rent their
ultrasound yeah keep it in like the
office no it's a little tiny ultrasound
wand and it plugs into your iPhone again
using what the smartphone as the brains
and that's why we're able to have things
like point-of-care Diagnostics is
because you've got that smartphone and
as the brains of it so really you just
need that Hardware of the sensor
component to go along with the brains
whoa okay so now I'm getting this
ultrasound wand from Phillips and we why
is it 300 a month to rent that it's not
seen my cell because you want to buy it
out maybe or like I don't know it seemed
like that was but that also is crazy for
a lot of people that want to get
frequent ultrasounds in certain for
Diagnostics well guess what 301 thinkin
do them as many times as you want or
maybe you are a remote clinic and you're
renting this right because you you can't
afford to have a large ultrasound
machine but your patient base can't
travel five hours to the nearest
hospital
we have parks in the United States that
are actually that remote and so we need
to start thinking about those as well
yeah you mentioned another important one
at the beginning what was the other one
that you mentioned EKG monitoring yes
sir this one's really cool this one's
coming out of Israel a company
cardiogram yes and so that's usually put
around this area to measure your heart
you have anywhere from 12 to 15 leads
you know those leads are you can see the
wires if you can imagine that and all
over and they're put in a very specific
way I'm not a healthcare professional so
I would not be able to administer this
to you but I could give you this shirt
to put on and the shirt putting it on
putting on the shirt it's a compression
shirt compression shirt yes so there's a
bunch of other ones on the market this
one actually has FDA approval and is ICU
quality real-time data which means you
can discharge patients earlier out of
the ICU and you can discharge them
earlier out of the hospital in general
and catch things when they start to go
downhill outside of these yeah exactly
so as soon as we start to see the EKG is
off we call you know mr. Jones and say
hey we can see this and and the patient
themselves will also be able to see it
the health as well as the healthcare
professional and then you can intervene
early before they actually need to be
hospitalized yeah again saving money
saving time saving lives saving live yes
yeah exactly
preventative healthcare yes actually
being healthy health not sick care not
post well that's still sick care but
it's it's trying to predict and make
sure that you don't get sicker because
at that point if you have to have an ICU
quality 12 to 15 lead EKG monitoring
shirt on 24 hours a day it's not because
your are practicing health most likely
it is because you are worried about a
heart attack or some type of cardiac
episode so when you initially titled the
book patient as the CEO it was because
oh so I am personally the CEO not only
of my entire healthcare team but also of
Robin ink and that's just the way I live
my life and so my personal backstory is
that I've had 43 hospitalizations six
major surgeries and three organs removed
for misdiagnosis I would have had a lot
of those hospitalizations anyway but I
would have kept most likely the organs
and so at the age of 26 I fired my
healthcare team took control of my
healthcare got a whole new set of
doctors nurses chiropractors whatever I
needed on the team at the time ended up
getting diagnosed correctly put on a
medication called Remicade which is a
biologic and I written to remission
overnight so that's why I named it that
you know the CEO of your own health care
team it saved my life not only did it
save my life but it gave me back my life
and it looks like you were the only one
that was interested in saving your life
you have to take anything done right
these days you're gonna do it just south
you're onto something Robin groans Ron
brings up a good point if for some
reason the initial Diagnostics about you
were not in of the highest caliber and
quality you had to take things by your
own reins and then drive them towards
your own health right and and it's not
that they weren't high quality its I was
at some of the top hospital systems in
the United States
it's that Diagnostics are that hard they
just really are that hard they have high
quality but they're dying to miss
diagnosing mm-hmm because especially
because you were taught we're talk I
have Crohn's disease so anything to do
with the GI system is incredibly
difficult to diagnose so I don't look
back I mean these were literally at the
top hospital systems on the East Coast I
don't look back and say oh they just
weren't doing their job well I look back
and say the technology wasn't there they
did the best they could at the time with
the with the amount of information they
had and as the patient it is my
responsibility to make sure that I'm
staying up on current events and I'm
constantly going and seeing new people
I have problems and if I'm in pain or if
I'm not able to live the life that I
want make sure that I go out there and I
get that help I need yeah I wonder what
the next so maybe we talk about this
what are these next stages of us taking
our our health into our own hands
so only first and foremost make sure you
are doing all the basic preventive
medicine things are you going do you you
practicing good sleep hygiene which
means go to bed and wake up pretty much
the same time seven days a week making
sure that you don't have disruptions in
the night and it's a dark room and it's
a certain temperature but there are
different things that you can do to make
sure that your sleep quality is as good
as it can be and then of course going to
things like exercise making sure that
you exercise every single day and do a
relatively healthy diet don't of course
skip the chocolate cake but these basic
things that you really need to make sure
that you have as a foundation and then
once you you can get those kinds of
things in place you can even take it up
a notch right and start to Metra size
and measure everything that you have and
and make it even a competition with
yourself and try to get to that next
level of being extra healthy so with all
this data that's gonna be coming in from
sensors and this point of point of care
at home we're gonna have a lot of data
with this and we're gonna have to learn
how to make it applicable to our lives
and hopefully do things like prevent
ourselves from getting sick yeah stay
healthy longer yep well there's some
other really important takeaways about
like health care revolution that we
should be aware it's an exciting time to
be in health care and it's exciting time
to be alive and take advantage of all of
these different technologies that are
that are hitting the market so in terms
of really taking control of your own
health there's a lot of digital stuff
that you can do now as well in the world
of AI it's not just these point of care
Diagnostics but you can do things like
measure your brain health because none
of us have a baseline on our brain
health which means we don't catch things
like dementia and Alzheimer's in the
very early stages when they're still
treatable by pharmaceutical
intervention so if you just take a five
to ten minute quiz once a month or once
a year you can have a baseline on your
brain health just like you have a
baseline on your heart rate and your
blood pressure and then measure tiny
little changes in your brain health to
make sure that you can intervene at
really early stages when it's still
either preventable or extremely
treatable yeah yeah the market for
digital therapy the market for being
able to analyze the biometrics and then
have a digitization of that data and
then make it relatable and then be able
to take therapeutic kind of steps to
maximize your own health seems like
we're it's gonna be at home right there
on the phone different wearables seems
like that's where we're going oh yeah
and the insurance companies are getting
in on the game so the major payers
companies like United and Humana they
have investment arms and they are
investing in what's called essentially
disease management software and and that
is that so managing something like
diabetes diabetes is an incredibly
expensive disease it's on a major
upswing it affects quite a large
percentage of the United States
relatively speaking and so insurance
companies are looking for those AI
solutions that will really help predict
B we predict before somebody gets too
sick right in the world of diabetes that
means potentially having an amputation
which is very expensive and of course
horrible for the patient it's gonna be
so much money saved yeah they'll be huge
yes if we can funnel that back into
innovation yeah yeah heck yes yeah and
it always makes me feel good to think
about not wasting money right yeah being
able to maximize the dollar yeah right
yes yeah there's a lot of wasted money
due to ignorance right now but that's
kind of also the human experiment as we
go through the phases of ignorance to
learn
and then how can we decrease the amount
of ignorance that we have so we can just
maximize our potential well you know
start putting a BCI chip in your head
with you down the brain computer
interface are you down of course but are
but are you down like are you like like
that's a question of course I am I mean
I'm really down too but I need a more
conversation around the ethics and the
philosophy and the programming the
design all that kind of stuff we just
needed more of a more round tables about
BCI's first and then I think we'll be
more down but a BCI doesn't necessarily
need to be invasive yeah I when you put
on a VR headset essentially that's a BCI
very nice even if you're reading neural
signature and then that's great but what
about writing through electromagnetic
stimulation and all that stuff yeah so
you can get you know transcranial
stimulated and controlled in a sense and
so I think it's important to also be
very you know skeptical about you know
who's making it oh we were just talking
about this weren't we yeah having who's
in control of that this technology
everything that we're working on in this
programming is can all lead to very bad
circumstances I just want to say that
it's garbage in garbage out right so how
do we get rid of the garbage are we
gonna take out the trash when are we
gonna take out the trash and who are we
to say who the trash is yeah well right
now the mind control is way more
limiting limited it's mostly mind
controlled by manipulation of economies
and politics incumbencies that's what
you know from what you know but but
that's like that's what it yeah and I
know nothing but that's like that branch
of it is kind of like the the key of
control right now when the key of
control is now transitioning to your
[ __ ] smartphone the thing that
everybody has in their pockets soon is
going to be a brain computer
face the control changes to an actual
100% objective plug right into that
person versus a oh well yeah when you
walk out the door your options are
limited because there's not a we don't
have fresh spinach where you live you
have to eat the burger and it's way
cheaper and you're poor so that's what
you have to do versus having a direct
implant so anyway rabbit hole of BCI's
so in my world in healthcare BCI's are
fantastic for people like paraplegic
yes stroke victims Alzheimer's dementia
anything that impacts the brain or the
the CNS the central nervous system right
so I'm really excited about that area
this might be a good time to talk about
mind maze yes okay let's do it mind maze
is fantastic this company based in
Switzerland and here in the United
States they have offices headquarters
here in San Francisco and it's doing us
virtual reality for stroke and brain
injury rehabilitation recently got FDA
approval for the micro Co which is the
at-home unit that you can take home
after a stroke and they also have the
FDA approval for the hospital based or
the clinic based unit as well and it's
really cool technology what happens is
in the world of VR pretend say your left
arm is partially paralyzed from a stroke
and what happens typically is you go
through physical therapy to try and get
at least a limited amount of motion back
and range of motion and all of that but
what we do in VR is we take a mirror
image of the right arm we layer it over
the left arm and that means when you
move your right arm in the world of
virtual reality it looks like your left
arm is moving and that is enough to
trick the brain into creating new new
ways of being able to map it so that you
can actually move it more it's amazing
and there's a significant number of
white papers that have come out of that
particular company heck yes yeah one
yeah that's one okay so I map my
right arm over my paralyzed left arm and
then I move that right arm in the
virtual world and then I'm actually
moving my left arm in the physical world
and that's how I'm slowly rehabilitating
myself yes and I'm building new neural
connections exactly I can just visualize
it in my head all these like can you
imagine we're able to manipulate with
the digital world new neural growth yes
for for rehabilitating an arm Wow
well I mean VR outside of mine Mays VR
in healthcare is being used now in quite
a different quite a few different
scenarios from especially PTSD with
military men there are a lot of
companies working on that anxiety
depression pain management or even for
pain and anxiety for say a dental
treatment so if you have a little kid
going in needs a shot or need some kind
of dental treatment putting in them in
into VR is enough of a distraction that
they don't even pay attention to the
fact that they just had a shot yeah yeah
so immersed into the VR that the
physical body getting worked on the
teeth or the shot or whatever is you
know your secondary exactly it's
distraction that's essentially what it
is a major distraction but I don't level
that we haven't seen before as human
beings it's very rare that I think about
distraction being good and so it's nice
to hear distraction being good in a
sense in the sense yeah
vr AR robotics AI sensor technology
digital health okay so that's okay
that's huge my mace huge awesome let's
talk about the thought leader formula
sure okay so this is the next book yes I
am already writing my next book it's
called the thought leader formula and
it's for executives and entrepreneurs to
really help drive business goals and
drive career goals because a lot of the
time especially in the world when you're
when you're in some type of a
corporation whether it's a startup or a
giant corporation sometimes the people
who do the most work get the least
recognition and
amount of promotions and salary
increases because they're not noticed
right and why are they not noticed oh
yeah because they're the ones with their
head down doing all the work so I'm
teaching that kind of person
not only that kind of that kind of
person how to be a thought leader so
that they can really increase their
ability to impact things but then also
the future of marketing is really all
about thought leadership so people
interact with people not with brands not
with companies and so having the CEO of
a corporation or actually any number of
representatives inside of the
corporation be thought leaders really
helps pull the company up with them
right and does a lot of the marketing
for them ok so then there's so many
people that are at work on a daily basis
that are hustling it out doing really
good work and then there's not so much
recognition and it's it's really
important to get recognition for the
work that we do so that we feel like
we're valued and they were right I mean
we actually a lot of the times like it
more than money
right if you you could make a hundred
thousand dollar salary but if everyone's
ignoring or what you do are taking
credit for your work that's a that's a
big thing as well inside of the
corporate world like what happens when
somebody takes credit for your work but
there's so much higher profile that you
can't fight against that you can't be
like hey wait no I'm the one who spent
600 hours on that report not you
this helps supersede that right because
all of a sudden you are as high profile
or higher profile and no one's gonna do
that to you anymore so what is what are
some of the principles then in the book
that tell the person that is work 600
hours on the report to step forward and
to say like hey that's my work and like
like I get recognition what are you well
I'm not even telling them to say you
know step forward and claim recognition
or anything like that
I'm giving them a formula and a set of
worksheets so I really take them through
a process on how to become a thought
leader and how to start building those
audiences and where do you think about
the ideas coming from so that that
doesn't happen too
going forward right what are some of
those so first and foremost thinking
about thought leadership as a business
right this isn't something that you're
gonna throw some Facebook posts up and
some Twitter posts and maybe some cute
messages and expect any type of traction
this is really a business and looking at
it just the way you would build a brand
for a new business build your brand and
this is your personal brand right and
when you're thinking about it as a
business then you need to think about
what's the business model and that's
first and foremost before you start
really doing anything else think about
what is my business model what where's
the revenue gonna come from because that
in itself is going to help determine how
you message things how you package
things up and even what potentially idea
that that you really turn into that
first initial thought we do vertical we
also have a session of like ethics and
philosophy or our own values and mission
because go whenever I hear like you know
business plan or business formula I'm
always thinking like did we sit down at
the table and talk about the ethics of
the technology or the philosophy around
it and how we bring it to the world and
so so so the brand so you're starting a
personal brand you can knowing your
essence your values all that stuff and
then going forth and getting a business
knowing where the money's gonna come
from and I'll take you through how to
kind of figure that out as well I'll
have a way for you to kind of list out
your skill set and brainstorm different
ways those skills turn into money
because I ran a conference called
innovation for jobs really on the future
of work and I understand what's going on
where technology is going to destroy
jobs but at the same time it's also
going to create jobs right so how do you
stay relevant it's no longer that
thirty-year job at a large you know
fortune 500 company that's not gonna
exist going forward so you're gonna
start looking at your at your life in
increments and what are those skill sets
that you have now that you can monetize
what are skill sets that you want to
develop over the next couple of years
that you can monetize and just thinking
about that as a lifelong process
and this is kind of future of work yes
yeah let's let's unpack this because if
the nine-to-five
for 30 years of the same company is dead
and people are starting to do you know
bits of their life you know I want to do
one year of my life working on this
creative aspect of this technology or
that whatever it ends up being what if
agnosticism is also true like you don't
need to actually go into a physical
office waste an hour commuting there and
back etc yeah so thought leadership
totally works with the future of work as
well exactly because basically you're
just creating a brand for yourself and I
call it putting your brain out there so
now that I've written a book and when my
second one publishes it's really easy to
access what I know so you understand how
I think and the kinds of things that I
know so I'm much more employable whether
that's as a consultant or a salaried
employee you know what you're getting
right yeah exactly and then if we can
put all your accomplishments and rather
than on like a LinkedIn profile we can
maybe stamp it on an immutable
decentralized ledger over time that's
also great hashtag blockchain I gotta
get that in there of course did not
expect blockchain to come up today
yeah there's so many applications of
biometrics and immutability that are so
important can you give us the scoop cuz
I thought this was really interesting
how does thought leadership affect the
me to movement oh yes so I've been in
Silicon Valley now for a quite a long
time and of course I've been sexually
harassed I've been bullied I've been
pushed down I've been abused in the
workplace it's it it is the stories
you're hearing it really is happening so
instead of trying to fight against that
I realized that early on you can't fight
against this gender bias you can't fight
against the sexual harassment very well
I mean it's just very contagious and a
very huge amount of stress and most of
the time the woman isn't isn't going to
win so instead just make yourself a
harder target right and that's what
thought leadership is
to do and I remember there was a
Business Insider article on that
interviewed me and I said now I am in a
tank and the men are on horseback hmm
right because it really gives me that
step-up so that uh seriously since my
book published in 2010 to 2015 I have
not been sexually harassed at all in the
workplace and before it was constant I
mean it was it was constant it was a
very specific and to that
it was it happened today it published
crazy so it is a massive protection and
it's coming at this problem from a from
a directional strength and power yeah
and owning it right versus the
victimization and correct yeah you can
always you can you can see it from
either side
totally totally I really think that
female leadership is so powerful I love
it yeah I love it we love being at women
and Technology International and doing
interviews there we love just all of the
powerful women in these different
industries and because we think that the
future is very female you know here look
at that look at that video of you
speaking you know you you're just stick
ulation you know the way you carry
yourself yeah this is so important these
are really important traits this part of
thought leadership is just straight-up
courage and confidence I actually have a
chapter on that how to gain that
confidence and credibility to be able to
do this yeah and a lot of the confidence
itself will come down to just knowing
your stuff and that's gonna be hard work
the first talk I ever did it was a 25
minute talk I practiced 40 times 4-0 not
only that but I hired a speaker coach
she recorded me and she gave me the
video and then I watched and I listened
to the video at least once a day for a
month no wait
I spent a huge amount of time preparing
for that very first 25 minute keynote it
went off without a hitch
I did not say um even one time yeah
not forget a work that's good then you
make note of that that's badass
you do it all the time island
yeah I got a stop filling space with the
word yeah that's right that's right as
you continue to do it yes exactly so
okay thought leadership for the me two
movements very interesting can be
empowered through us through leadership
and and that way we can do things like
take stages give really powerful talks a
write book start companies get funding
for companies yeah higher salaries right
easier consulting jobs anything you want
me no more well-known you are and the
more well-known that your ideas are the
more hireable you are first you get the
money then you get the power then you
get there women that's so missus you
know that's from Scarface nobody you
know of course remember I can do the
exact same thing from the female's
perspective first you get the money then
you get the power then you get the men
or make Mitch McConnell is he's a big
guy still I don't know who's that we
can't talk about these things and we
well the the beauty of it is like the
heroines journey at the same time as the
hero's journey right the year these
journeys that are going on and whenever
I see the heroines journey I think to
myself like you know what's going on in
the heroines journey like what does it
feel like for a woman because you know
for women there are different you know
they're tapped into energy in a
different way that and then then men are
and many times in many ways and so you
know thinking about it like holy cow
what does your low look like what does
it feel like what does your high look
like what does that feel like who do you
go to when you're really low how do you
pull through the low so hearing all
these different aspects to the heroines
journey and having somebody be writing
about thought leadership that's close to
us is this is really important yeah yeah
we're we're super grateful to have
people that are inspiring other people
to build a bright future sitting across
from us like that's one of the things
that we care about a lot on the show and
you're writing a book to do so at a big
scale so we hope to you know Lincoln bio
for
patient as CEO and soon we'll add the
link when is it like six months is it it
will be out January February and I'll be
launching an online program as well did
you did you have any promotional
material for this book that we could
have been privy I guess okay not yet and
soon a couple of months I'm still
writing it let's see let's ask you a
couple of our simulation questions first
I mean the first question we talked
about this a decent amount on the show
but I think this is really applicable to
especially you but what is the future of
the decentralisation of data as well in
general and also general data and
privacy for yeah yeah let's talk about
both healthcare but also and for all
applications I mean it's really early to
think about in health care there are a
couple of big things going on that are
trials like Walmart dipping their toe
into to block change slightly and things
like that what its gonna be best for is
of course things like the billing and
and the EMRs so our EMR is right now our
medical records yeah electronic medical
records now most clinics are on
electronic medical records but the
problem is is the interoperability and
different systems don't work with
different systems think about like
Microsoft vs Apple but we've got like 10
major players in the world of healthcare
that are apples and Microsoft's all
using different platforms I can take the
clinical record from where you just were
and apply it to the next clinic not
usually yeah not easily so it's the
transfer of these EMRs and not only with
outside of the hospital but within the
same hospital system sometimes the like
emergency room EMR doesn't work with say
the OBGYN clinics EMR in the same
hospital system so this is a major
problem so that is one of the things
that might be able to provide some type
of a solution but you do have to worry
about things like the HIPAA stuff right
access control to the data mm-hmm so
it's not just the access control to the
data but it's getting the data there
right so even if you've got the most
secure you know decentralized block team
platform that you could possibly have
you still have
to get the data there and and then that
prevent people from tapping in right
because we have very strict laws around
health and privacy with HIPPA laws right
yeah okay we kind of tapped into this a
little bit when we were talking about
BCI's brain computer interfaces but what
do you think is the exponential
technology that's going to augment the
human race the most ai-ya-ya and where
do you see the most profound
augmentations with AI for the human race
well it's just the ability to let me
give you an example
three scan it's this early stage startup
company it can do in one day using
machine learning and some special
cameras and stuff that they do use that
it would take a traditional pathologist
one year so really accelerating learning
what yeah that's huge what are they
what's the pathologist usually takes a
year to find what are they what are they
foot disease are they finding oh this is
it's complicated right so like
pathologists they could be looking at
any any amount of things from from the
human body right so the point is is that
what and one year's worth of the
pathologist time equals one day worth in
this particular yeah company called
three scans so that's that's already an
existence so like that's that kind of
the Delta that you need to come out
there 364 days of time saved and also
more more efficient reading and scanning
right I need a sleep yeah that much more
progress with diseases in general yeah
yeah okay cool so you continue kind of
linking back the most profound things
about AI is kind of a savior of time
savior of time it's fantastic at pattern
analysis
yeah so anything to do with Diagnostics
when you're talking about imaging right
radiology it's fantastic decision
support software for radiology because
that's all that's doing is it's
analyzing images
and that's just data so the big problem
with it one of the problems with AI is
that it just needs that much data we do
have it coming out but I think the the
general expression is that life begins
at a billion data points so you can't
just start to you know wire up maybe
four people and get enough okay here's
the queers a question what advancements
are happening in the United States that
are not that are happening you may be
even better in Europe or in China where
in these other places in the world do
they have healthcare advancements that
are going on or even advances in AI that
you're aware of that are outpacing the
US and ways well Japan is much better
than we are and a lot of the robotics
right do you know which ones they've got
pepper yeah right and companies like
that so pepper is really one of the
first robotics yes exactly and and he's
awesome but what we're gonna what we're
gonna see is for everyone who doesn't
know what pepper is this is it's about
four feet tall and it's a robot but it's
just essentially a companion it's little
arms can't actually lift anything it's
not gonna bring you anything it can
dance and amuse you so essentially it's
a companion yeah yes and this is being
used as concierge Azure in hospitals or
grocery stores so as a customer service
representative type role but you can
also of course have them in the home now
that being one of the first over the
next two or three years we're going to
see a massive explosion in home robots
and they aren't necessarily going to
look like a humanoid robot like like a
pepper type thing some of them are just
looking like Amazon Alexa so really
Amazon Alexa and Google home these are
personal robots in the home right yeah
so we're gonna see a lot more yeah
there's thanks Ronda for very adorable
yes so this is a companion robot so
again this is things like me talking to
the Google assistant or to Siri or to
Amazon Alexa and me asking the questions
maybe asking for I get some emotion here
I get to see some facial expression I
get to see some hand movement
some dancing dancing some bright colors
so the really cool thing about a lot of
these not just pepper in particular is
that they are platforms so that means
other companies can build apps on it as
skill sets so you know artificial narrow
intelligence or A&I and these also worm
so the more you interact with them the
more personalized it gets to your
particular personality and your likes
and dislikes I can hear some stress in
your voice
I'll play some calming music exactly
exactly right and it's gonna anticipate
your needs there's one coming out on the
market later on this year from from Asia
called rocky robots and it's adorable
little robots like I think he's about
from here up and it's specifically for
Millennials and what they like and what
they love to do and all of that do you
know what it's gonna do it's gonna
interact like Amazon elects it's gonna
interact yes Millennials yes there's
another one coming out of Israel very
specific for elder care so they're
targeting their little robot and it
doesn't even look like a robot it looks
more it doesn't even look like Amazon
Alexa but more like an object type thing
with an ability to have video so that
for eldercare you can interact with your
family interact with your healthcare
professionals or whatever you whatever
you're doing and there is one for
childhood that's um coming out and this
year I know we're gonna have them on the
show and they're ready hi pals should be
on the market soon if they're not
already I thought they should be on the
market but I Pal is looks like pepper
and but smaller and it's specific for
both dementia but also child care
because it is that smaller robot if you
ever went through the San Jose Airport
you saw some of I fell they they
sometimes have a l-pipe al in the
airport just as a demonstration unit you
so live in Palo Alto I know you
reference the San Jose Airport instead
of the San Francisco Airport they're so
close to each other they're only like 40
miles away the airports and Palo Alto
Sam Singh only 40 miles away they can be
like a world of difference when it's a
two-hour drive in traffic DePaul
I forgot that I was in San Francisco for
a moment because I'm so used to being in
Palo Alto yeah yep there's the eye-pal
so okay so the age of robots that are
our companions and senses and also have
the vast myriad of data about not only
us but also on all of the internet that
they can tap into for information for us
for helping us out helping us live
better saving us time all that good
stuff
okay let's talk about this quick because
I do still want to learn about it act
Avalon act Avalon yep just teach us
about curing cancer with the p53
processes so we are an early-stage small
molecule oncology company working both
with the pathway p53 and a HR ahr may
also be a big deal in the world of
autoimmune disease but the big deal with
p53 and the farmers have spent billions
of dollars trying to crack this code is
that when you get cancer and 50% of the
time about what happens is it
infiltrates the cell and p53 finds it
and realizes that cancer is coming
knocking on the door and it kills the
cell but in 50% of cancer cases p53 is
damaged and so imagine and it doesn't
look anything like this but if you are a
complete layperson not a biologist think
about a walnut and the walnut show is
the p53 and when that's cracked then the
cancer can take over the cell or the
walnut and
and once it does that it can replicate
and replicate and replicate and that's
what happens the protein acts as a
defense mechanism and so what happens is
it's what kills the human cell when it
detects cancer and when that is damaged
it can no longer kill the human cell
which allows the cancer to spread if you
go in there and repair the damaged p53
it can then do its job of killing the
cells whenever it detects cancer and we
should be able to treat or cure
potentially 50% of all cancer and is
this an immunotherapy done uh it's it's
a small molecule it's a small molecule
and then it just powers up my p53
protein into my cells it just powers it
to Oh
like the deep deep science so yeah
there's there's no way to explain it in
layman's terms that that even I couldn't
impart to you guys but okay yeah just
imagine some cool small molecules going
in there and we're pairing c-53 what are
you saying we're not that smart
come on give us a go I think it's just
you that's not that smart
what it says like dumb I'm smart and I
want respect
I'll respect see you're the good-looking
one with funny accent that was Fredo
from The Godfather you didn't know I'm
dating myself on that one with my disco
she's nice I'm glad Ron got called good
looking looking yourself Robin we can't
say that anymore though either those
days are over
sorry let's get back to the show please
come on I don't think those days are
over we can slap friendly-like hey you
look really it's a 15-minute timer wow I
did not expect that it was almost like I
was in the middle of Star Wars with some
kind of lightsaber yeah yes yeah and
then the 15 minute glass comes out we're
not we're not we're not done with it
people can still say you're looking good
yeah you looking good too like we can
still we still get there we will we'll
keep we'll keep doing that you know okay
okay couple questions on the way out so
what do you think's going on exponential
technology is continuing to exacerbate
wealth inequality in many ways but the
bottom is still like slowly coming up in
terms of SES but the top is just
exploding what do you think's gonna
happen with wealth inequality that will
probably continue I will we'll start
we'll see a lot more of people getting
yeah a lot more people who are much
wealthier right so almost no
middle-class and squeezing out the
middle class and just having a little
lower on the upper classes right Ron
right a throw the quotas yeah if it's
the end of the middle class pick a side
people pick a side that's all you can do
I'm glad you come to terms with that
Robin and you
stand that you see that you know it's
not gonna ya Allen's get this utopian
Logan's Run world where I'll live
forever and everybody's dancing around
the Maypole love each other we can you
know be immortal you might with your
generation yeah it might happen but so
check this out though although you two
are correct that the wealth and
qualities being exasperated to a point
where it's looking like it could be the
end of the middle class you got to pick
a society they're gonna be poor you and
be rich etc that it might not be just
the straight-up with brain computer
interfaces and all these retraining
methods there might be actually pretty
easy to take people that have maybe
lower IQs or people that have just a
less of a drive to want to do anything
every day
and help them become more motivated and
more intelligent to make change but of
course yeah
like artificial intelligence is just so
much more intelligent than even the
smartest people on the bell curve so
then what the what the f is gonna happen
when humans are rendered you know
completely useless hopefully not but I
don't think that they're ever gonna be
compute completely useless we still need
that human connection we're still
animals that that go in herds like that
so unless the AI is really
indistinguishable but if the
preservation of life is the ultimate
goal even past the death of our star in
the death of this solar system then just
preserving consciousness digitally and
sending that off to colonize other parts
of the galaxy for now is a good idea and
so you know we'll see anyway the we got
very sci-fi D quick but yeah yeah hey
hey hey
but you actually mentioned the end of
the no class now now what do you see
happening though with well if you think
about it right now even the people who
are especially in the United
dates in the most poverty stricken
they're still living considerably better
than they did a hundred years ago right
someone who was in poverty at the same
level say if you were looking at it as a
percentage they were living so much
worse 100 years ago so in 50 years maybe
the people who are at the far end of the
poverty spectrum are living maybe as
well as say someone who is just regular
poor now right now sorry and so maybe we
can make sure with with this abundance
that technology can help yeah give us
eradicate suffering yeah so these dire
the people who are in dire straits maybe
we can get them shelter and safety and
food and if those those baseline needs
met which never before has been possible
in human history yeah gosh like Amazon's
building houses for like five thousand
bucks a house it's gonna drop in price
dramatically the 3d printing houses
right get better and better and better
yeah cost of housing is gonna draw I
mean the cost of making the housing
structure not the cost of land cost of
land is still yeah enough that's why
that's why a lot of people live right
here on Market Street because they're
centrally located you can't put a five
thousand dollar house in the middle of
the street but you can just lay there
with a sleeping bag and wake up the next
day and be centrally located again and
so who knows if if there will be a
movement to try and you know move people
off the street you know hopefully what
if they don't want to there's so many
there's so many things that go into play
there well they have a clear conscience
to you know they don't play their game
they live in a street they can you know
that dude right or wrong they're just
it's not participating they're still
alive you know it could be a rigged game
you know that they just don't want to
play they want to play the raid game
yeah yeah Robin what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world oh I
don't know we're just ability to be
alive is amazing so maybe that's it just
the life itself
do you think that there's consciousness
coming through your physical form or is
it localized here physically so I have
synesthesia and you do yeah oh sweet I
love synesthesia I get it every once in
a while everyone yeah it turns on and
off I don't have control over it so I
actually can see sometimes people
outside of themselves oh that's sweet
yeah we were to sound like radiating
there was this was so crazy um there's a
filmmaker out there named Tiffany and
she was she made a film and she's
Tommy's last name
slain yeah it's George slain sister yeah
I had Jordan on the show oh I didn't saw
her movie when she just had first
released it I mean years ago five six
years ago at least and she talked about
her synesthesia a little bit in the
movie and how she sees Jordan as green
and I was like cuz I see him as green oh
yeah it was crazy and so when after the
movie cuz it was like a special
screening for friends type of thing I
went up to her and I was like I he's
that color for me too and and yeah it
was just mind because you had never
talked about him being green I never
talked about that with anybody and I
didn't know Tiffany that well I just met
her a couple of times at that point and
I had no idea that she had sent us these
because there's all these different
colors that he could be - yeah and so
the I wonder if yeah I wonder if that
has to do with his essence the soul
maybe that you both seem that way
whether you both do maybe and I can
actually sense pure evil as well and I'd
have met it what's the hell and so I
went looking at me for no he's not yeah
I know beauty I used to speak Farsi and
I was with a friend of mine who happened
to be a pathologist I don't know why
I've said that word so many times today
but random and we were walking down the
street and we saw one of his academic
partners who was also a pathologist and
he came up and he started talking and my
brain went completely dead
and I could not think of a word in
English or Farsi and he was he was
Persian that's why yeah that's why I
speak with my new boys in Fremont there
yeah my African friends as well and my
brain just went dead and I couldn't
think or move or talk or anything I was
just kind of like this and when he
walked away I looked at my pathologist
physician friend and I I'm like he's
he's pure evil right and and he's like
oh yeah that guy is probably the most
evil man I've ever met and my friend had
known him for a year at that point and I
was like I could send census so much
that it shut me shut me down completely
what was his behavior like it was just
like hi my name is Fred it's a nice day
out how are you my idol wow this is
crazy okay all right so I was the only
time I've sensed it at that level like I
you know there's a lot of people who are
very acute mean or little be evil or
something this was someone who was on
the far end of the spectrum that I
didn't think existed whoa that is crazy
I don't know if I've met someone like
that I I ran like I I could not get away
from there fast enough and I'm telling
you he did nothing wrong it was just
like hi my name is I don't remember his
name at this point hi my name is Fred
you could hear that okay a couple couple
more questions on the way out do you
think we're alone in the cosmos Oh
course not come on what would is life
outside of this life look like to you we
can't even imagine it so right now think
about trying to imagine another sense
sense of smell sense of taste sense of
touch can you imagine another sense no
because we just are tapping into like
electromagnetic no I mean like something
that no one's ever talked about before
right you just can't you can't imagine
unknown unknown yeah yeah yeah so
there's no way to really imagine what
other things might exist out there that
have completely different shapes
census or if it's even in other
dimensions or if there's multiple
dimensions going on multidimensionality
yeah I would say my mind is open to all
of those possibilities that's - yeah yes
right do you think there's a designer to
the universe a creator there's something
out there but I don't know if it's a
single entity a simulator to the
universe it could be you know there
might be something that's not in the
base reality or do you think you live in
the simulation they don't know cuz oh
yeah I kind of actually think that
sometimes I wonder if I if I live in the
if I live in a simulation or if it's
this is IRL yeah is this in real life or
is this a situation because when you
look at stuff like this you know look at
the delay on that move your hand again
do that you know yeah so it's just it's
just uh there's there's no simulation
that's you in a simulation so how is
this not one yeah yeah yeah yeah awesome
what a great conversation Robin thank
you for joining us on the show we
greatly appreciate it thank you so much
for having me yes and we have patient as
CEO link in the bio check it out also
definitely check out a lot of the other
content that we talked about today so
I'm go take a look at that also get
ready for more thought leader formula
that'll be coming out in about six
months I'm going practice some of these
things that you learn today so take two
things that you learn go share them with
two people have them go share it with
two people and let's go start getting
more of the stop provoking conversation
going on in the world so give us the
subscribe comment below with your
thoughts we'd love to hear from you also
join us on patreon help us continue
sustaining and supporting and growing
this we'd love for you to join us
thanks everyone for tuning in thanks Ron
our producing partner much love peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]